hey Nick oh come on man all right guys
listen a couple things
I know you've been riding around on the
hoverboards a lot that's cool and all
I'm all down with the new kids
technology but I mean we got a walk so
we're gonna start doing intervals for
hundreds for you for by 1200 and yeah
you're gonna do 200 or 400 every day
that we upload a corridor digital videos
we're going to on the day it's uploaded
sit down and livestream us going through
the YouTube comments we're gonna read
them and make fun of ourselves the
internet stuff well there's a Google
Form was it posted anywhere yet link of
the description of the Saturday blog I
want you to want to watch every vlog
it's just a meta thing we're second
would it be easier for you to film if
Sam we're sitting over here what if I
need information you know phone there we
go scoot it up look at that we're not
just in my own space I can't like these
wheels don't scoop very well I need a
new chair you sit in that chair okay
going back I can't handle this now I'm
sitting here it is how much more
productive meeting sweet it is a lot
more productive this upcoming release I
think you could actually try to release
the label yet
we're all kind of hoping to have a
little bit of time to recover from
traveling we could shoot tomorrow the
outline calls for like a little model
blegh it's good summer we add that means
we have to get today okay it's probably
one of us as the I guess the power you
know how to handle this you handle this
bleep stick you know this right you're
linebacker right you should know that
quarter-turn at the 40 ready hit it
there you go Oh effects and the moments
are simple then that means the videos
just core concepts should just be robust
at a random day in the life or it's like
oh my powers and then I do like this
much with them and that's the end of
video feels so much more real to
acknowledge how a dangerous and easy it
is to turn someone into Legos I got my
vibration dampening bobbins and I can't
replace and I cannot put a GoPro on
their GoPro on oh so I got like no yeah
no [ __ ] get out of here you go alright
yeah you come the room with me for a
second no one's going to the roof and
it's especially not you I'm getting
really annoyed with you taking hours out
of every day of while you're growing on
sub-sites these bags last of six minutes
I fly two of them multiple times a day I
do it twice this is this conversation
enough is enough
enjoy video let's work related this
patreon campaign yeah I got to talk to
you stand up
what Stan what are you doing I know
listen this is very important this coat
what is this you kiss your mother in
that coat yeah actually you might be
taken seriously in life yes sweet you
got this coat on you're too skinny drink
this 25 mil I want you to drink three of
these I want you to take three of these
everyday and then will you read my
outline and I want you to take off that
goddamn coat here's what's going to
happen we get the people there and we'll
start blogging it out and then you're
going to figure out something that works
you're right now you're trying to get to
the nuances of how the like how's the
beat go to work hard and motivate is
pushing make it not look weird can't
conceptualize that anymore you get the
actors on the spot to figure it out on
the spot for a 3/10 to pretend I'm
professional
later trust me it'll work great I don't
trust you I don't trust you aren't you
tired I was hoping for an extra day to
prepare but that's not how we roll on
YouTube check this out I just built this
so good yeah
you guys are slow I just built this I'm
finished yellow roof yet someone because
this the Internet is gonna point out
well why didn't his keyboard turn into
Legos problem solved my girls on my
fingers yes remember that desk is
dangerous am I gonna get this shot
without showing the desk I'm literally
looking at just getting nice and close
to my fingy
so Tiger it's frozen trying to export
the obj this is a choke point I didn't
expect maybe it won't work hey this is
Dominus just abandon it